we've survived camping in the Arctic
we've survived camping in the Rockies
we've survived camping without food or
water but can we survive the cheapest
gear Walmart has to offer let's go give
it a try all right I'm ready to rob the
store I mean go shopping all right okay
now hands down the cutest sleepy bag
around are these 50-degree bags from
Ozark trails 9:97 the only way you can
go cheaper is by grabbing the covers off
your bed and bringing those camping
instead which isn't a bad idea by the
way but keep in mind the 50 degree
rating is a little bit generous normally
these bags are only comfortable at 60 to
70 degrees depending on what you wear to
bed and how warm of a sleeper you are
one of the biggest factors in what keeps
you warm is the mattress you use and
hands down the cheapest mattresses are
the inflatable ones you can get a twin
size air mattress for 797 because we got
three campers in one tent we're gonna go
ahead and get the queen-size and it's
only 1497 without the pump if you need a
pump you can get the battery powered
pump that takes six C batteries for
eleven dollars or you can pay a little
over 15 bucks for the hand pump and then
you don't have to buy all the C
batteries okay hands down the cheapest
tents around at the Ozark Trail brand
tents they come in three men for man and
six man tents the three men is only 25
dollars when it says the three person
tent what that really means is three
normal-sized adults sleeping in very
close proximity to each other with no
room for their gear or it's good for one
adult and two small kids with some of
their gear we need some cookware and by
far the cheapest one is this little
8-inch cast-iron pans there are a ton of
flashlights here and by far the cheapest
ones are $1.00 P so we're gonna go ahead
and grab three of those they've got the
battery inside of a little button on the
back well we're looking at mess kits and
there's a lot of different options the
cheapest is this two-man combo set for
547 so you've got plates Bowl spoons for
two
people 597 looks like they got a few
dehydrate meals and the cheapest one is
the Ice Cream Sandwich all right for
cookware don't buy camping gear go to
the kitchen section of Walmart and
you'll find the cheapest stuff cutting
board 88 cents kitchen knife 297 with
sheath you can get this 8 quart pot for
only 694 it's about 20 bucks cheaper
than if you were to buy a camping
cooking pot classics wooden spoon for
stirring stuff 197 now you can't buy all
this stuff for camping or you can just
raid your wife's kitchen and hope that
she's okay with that that's another
viable strategy if any of you are a
little bit of cold sleepers you can get
these adhesive body warmers that last 12
hours and you can put them on your
jammies or in your bag and they work
really great 15 bucks gets you a 12
quart Igloo cooler now we need a knife
and a hatchet or a saw or something and
the cheapest knife is dollar 97 this
little thing of a jiggy and the cheapest
saw is the commando saw for 444 I'm sure
this is exactly what the commandos used
cheapest camping chairs 597 apiece all
right we got all this gear we need to
put it in something and we've got all
these bins and the only bin that'll fit
the folding chairs and everything else
is actually the one with wheels which is
the one I wanted anyways and it's 1997
[Music]
one of the cheapest meals on a camping
trip is hot dogs
looks like these Oscar minor wieners for
224 are the cheapest ones they got here
now we're kind of kind of out of stock
Walmart great value brand hot dog buns
87 cents nice thing with hot dogs too is
you don't need to bring mess kids or
cooking utensils or any of that garbage
just you know get yourself a wiener
stick and you're good to go we're gonna
go cheap and do the hot dogs but I'm
also gonna prepare a little bit better
meal I've got some cubed beef steak I'm
gonna make Costa Rican casado which is
basically beans and rice it's a great
affordable camping food that's very very
delicious the boil and bagged rice is
absolutely wonderful and the cheapest
stuff is 228 so there we go
58 cents a can a couple cans of sliced
carrots 50 cents apiece and you want to
make sure you get the pull top lid so
you don't have to bring a can opener and
need some onions for the beans and rice
cheapest seasoning you can buy salt and
pepper pack 2 bucks cheapest breakfast
you can buy pancakes a pancake mix for a
buck 68 and a whole thing of syrup for
133 for less than four dollars you can
feed a ton of people all right we gotta
get some marshmallows and cheapest
marshmallows are the Yamal Oh
rainbow ones 98 cents if you go camping
or you need water jugs to store your
water in and 80 cents for one gallon of
drinking water is way cheaper than
buying a bunch of empty water jugs
alright there's everything we need to go
camping plus a few things my wife asked
me to pick up let's go check out and see
how much it cost I just realized I
forgot lighter
there you go [ __ ] 97
so about enough gear for me and my two
oldest boys to go camping but there was
a lot of optional items in there we
didn't need to buy folding chairs and we
could have borrowed kitchen utensils
from home instead of buying camping
utensils well I bought camping gear for
me Tommy and Natan in order to test it
out properly I brought all the family so
there's all five of us are gonna test
this out it's gonna be fun let's see
what happens
tonight we're the camp and tomorrow we
got some really fun activities we are
gonna go fossil hunting tomorrow there's
actually a beach nearby
where you can find tons of fossils and
so we're gonna take the kids fossil
hunting tomorrow but first we gotta get
dinner made we got to get camp set up we
had a lot to do one thing I didn't
include in my budget was firewood a lot
of places bringing your own firewood
illegal because of parasites and bugs
and that's a big problem in our area so
we have to use bought firewood what'd
you find
those are thick guys look at them well
at the last minute my wife agreed to
come with us
but mama don't do Walmart challenges so
I've got my memory foam fishing caught
here with all the bells and whistles and
I'll I'll show you a little bit more huh
what I got for her she's she's going to
be sleeping in luxury all right I got
the kids running around collecting
sticks for the fire and we're gonna try
out a couple of our knickknacks here
we've got the commando saw and the
pocketknife lock blade knife pretty
basic here okay so here's my saw let's
try this thing out here I got stuck
all right it's kind of biting into it Oh
take that big stick to the fire okay
good job this is the little
battery-operated pump for the air
mattress works great for stoking the
fire
[Applause]
yeah I go find some marshmallow sticks
and find one for Jacob - well this
dollar 97 knife feels and works like a
dollar 97 knife it's it's not that great
and this commando saw leaves much to be
desired but it does technically work is
that worth five dollars and 50 cents or
whatever it is check out our three
person tent
I realized that I didn't double check to
make sure a queen mattress would fit
inside this three-man tent so we're
gonna find out together coming along
nice you like having all the kids in the
tent these rectangular sleeping bags can
unzip and fold out like a blanket and
you can take two of them and zip them
together to make a double size sleeping
bag it keeps the kids warmer and it's a
more efficient use of sleeping bags
because you get more kids per sleeping
bag the boys have been jumping on the
air mattress and they've stretched it
out and so I need to put some more air
in it now
[Music]
alright Tom you're roasting a hot dog
good job man
so what do you think of the dollar
ninety seven nights like tickling that
stick we're just sitting here playing we
already found our first tick on Jacob
don't put him in the fire or in the food
I'm not sure we worry with so I'm making
Costa Rican beans and rice here it's
called casado
and I'm using the Lin's on Oh salsa for
the flavor is stuff is so good oh yeah
all right we got to bust open our mess
kits here so let's see what we got we
got utensils that's some sort of
collapsible bowl or cup and we got a
plate here Costa Rican beans and rice
what do you think of the mess kit well
millions of South Americans can't be
wrong
beans and rice is affordable and
delicious campfire food yeah it really
is got a deep lip on it oh you want to
eat marshmallows all right get your
stick you can smell these marshmallows
why would smell these marshmallows yeah
these were these were like 80 cents oh
did you roast your marshmallow yeah yeah
we eat that now they're marshmallow
looks like black bear scat what do you
think of the marshmallows Becca
now that dinners been eaten we need to
set up Becca's tent and Becca's bed
Becca is going to sleep well tonight so
that she might come back with us some
more can't be
so while me and the three boys will be
sleeping in the three-man tent my wife
will be enjoying the luxury of this
eight-man Field & Stream dome tent all
right let me show you my wife's sleeping
system and yes I said sleeping system
it's made by a British carp fishing
company called Fox and it's specifically
designed for carp fishing take a seat
first off it's extra wide extra-long and
it's got these little ridges on the edge
so it cradles you in the center and you
don't roll off it's got these fully
articulating feet that are adjustable so
you can make it extra high off the
ground and you can adjust it if you're
not on level surfaces but the best part
is this sleeping bag attaches to the cot
it hooks on right here on the head and
then there's a strap here in the middle
and it slides over the feet so you can
toss and turn and get up and get back
into your bag and it doesn't get all
bunched up and fall off your cot it
stays attached to your cot and of course
we've got a camping pillow - all right
time to review another product let's try
the dehydrated Ice Cream Sandwich you
guys ready for dessert marshmallows
weren't dessert there were a side dish
pick it up look at it looks like a legit
Ice Cream Sandwich try some of that
dehydrated ice cream where you think
Nathan do you like it a little kind of
mixed reviews on the ice cube see how
much but it really does taste like a
warm crunchy Ice Cream Sandwich oh look
it's the first Firefly of the year oh
there we go
Firefly
godwyn Jacob you got well see look he's
glowing
all right boys it's bedtime grab your
flashlights and everyone hop in the tent
okay oh okay
now we get the hand warmers out now
we're going stick this to your back and
that'll keep you warm for 12 hours
it's glamping time now the kids are to
bed we are testing the mess kits to make
sure that they work on personal sized
cherry pies maybe work so well we're
gonna finish up all this pie testing and
then go to sleep and tomorrow we are
going fossil hunting and we'll continue
to give you our opinion on the cheapest
gear from Walmart
well we ended up using the two sleeping
bag zip together for all three of us
that worked really well actually
made a really nice pillow which reminds
me I should have brought ballast
look guys I made a little friend he
likes me that is a huge mah this I'll
make you make you some breakfast all
right now that we finished breakfast let
me tell you what I think of the tent and
our sleeping situation here I don't know
how long it will last and when it will
spring a leak but it was cheap and it
was actually pretty nice be frank and
three of us fit on it pretty well I
wouldn't want to put three adults on it
but two adults or adult and two kids no
problem it's raining lightly on and off
and it looks like it's gonna do that
throughout the day so we're gonna pack
up everything and put it in the car and
then we're going fossil hunting
well we're all packed up and ready to go
and I'll tell you what out of all the
things we bought the only two that I
wouldn't use again for the knife and the
saw everything else for the price was
great but enough of that it's time to go
fossil hunting you guys ready to go
follow me all three of our children have
just bitten in the first five minutes
whoa tides way up
we usually find a couple dozen fossils
when we come here but it'll be a bit
challenging today the key is to wander
around in your bare feet and feel for
gravel and when you find some scoop it
up with the bass all right I got a spot
with a little bit of gravel here we're
gonna try digging
all right been doing it three minutes
and we already found one see if you can
see it there's a big old fat fossilized
shark-tooth right there look at that
that's a really nice one where do you
find one you often find more this right
here is part of a fossilized scallop
call the chess effective nephron
alright we got another one Tommy found
it first show where it is Tommy
there it is look at this one it's in
great shape that's a different species
of shark I complete shark tooth and a
piece of the shark teeth right there
Oh another one a piece of one we're up
to about seven or eight of them now
they're they're all over the place the
boys are getting cold I think we need to
call it I don't know what's better the
wet cold diaper on my neck or looking
through a basket well guys we had a good
cold wet time found about half a dozen
shark teeth and I just had a great time
camping as a family hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you guys want to
see more videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that belt like
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching